[Music]
are you learning anything about sex that
you didn't know before
by doing this show yes I uh the speed of
a man's ejaculate I just learned what
yeah do you know it no I don't know I've
never used a baseball radar nice so
you're talking about the speed yeah we
know the you know comes out yes I mean
you want to take a guess what no because
wouldn't it vary from man to man
apparently it's apparently I have heard
as a constant it's a stable constant oh
no I don't I don't know I guess twelve
miles an hour in a school zone but it is
a book like your children live here
it's 27 miles per hour which is also
what is seven months yeah 27 miles an
hour
and is impressive also the shaving
getting a mile yeah
did that yeah
look out northern but it's also it's
also that is the sake it's the same as I
guess like 26 point something but it's
the same exact speed that Hussein bolt
ran like the fastest man alive the same
speed as the fastest man so I figured
out that if he was like run sprinting
full speed and ejaculated while doing so
it would just stay inside
[Applause]
you